tous les possesseurs de smartphones se
sont posé la question à un moment ou à
un autre est ce que nos téléphones nous
écoute avec des publicités ciblées de
plus en plus précises qui nous
connaissent de mieux en mieux et qui
nous donne l'impression que notre
téléphone aurait enregistré et divulguer
des informations sur nos conversations
pour facture on répond à cette question
et si vous voulez être certain de ne pas
avoir un mouchard auprès de vous resté
jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo
[Musique]
commençons par nous pencher sur les
téléphones
ces outils considéré comme indispensable
pour 79% des 18-35 ans sont également
une source d'inquiétude pour nombre
d'entre nous 78% des français pensent
tout risque lié à l'utilisation de leur
donner un exemple concret de cette
inquiétude ce sont ces publicités pour
un produit qui apparaissent soudainement
alors qu'on vient d'en parler en
présence d'un téléphone portable ça nous
arrive à tous au milieu d'une
conversation d'avoir un téléphone qui
répond à une question ou qu'ils se
mêlent de la conversation alors les
grands fabricants affirment que non ils
ne nous écoutent pas ce qui pourrait
être considéré comme inquiétant c'est
surtout que la captation et pas du tout
réglementer il n'y a pas deux il n'ya
pas de réglementation absolument dédié à
ça mais il y avait évidemment le
règlement général de protection des
données européen le fameux airs gpd qui
implique quand même un consentement à
partir du moment où des données
personnelles sont sont obtenus tous les
objets connectés sont ne sont que des
réceptacles pour recevoir cette donnée
personnelle pas plus pas moins l'enjeu
il est sûr la donne et il n'est pas sur
le téléphone un mur en fait ce sont pas
les téléphones en tant que tel qui pose
question mais plutôt les applications
qu'on installe dessus qui exigent un
accès total ou partiel à nos données
quand vous avez un pop up sur votre
ordinateur qui vous demandent l'accès ou
l'autorisation d'accéder à des données à
vos données posez vous les bonnes
questions à partir du momment on
autorise une application à utiliser
micro du téléphone portable on peut tout
à fait légitimement se poser la question
de ce à quoi ça ou même on peut craindre
que parfois il y en ait qui soit pas
tout à fait respectueux de la vie privée
par exemple en 2018 suite au scandale
cambridge analytique à mark zuckerberg
pdg de facebook avait été interrogé sur
la question nationale de facebook
non
effectivement à ce jour personne n'a
prouvé que les principales applications
de réseaux sociaux installé sur un
téléphone simplement posé sur une table
enregistrer et diffuser massivement à
notre insu toutes nos conversations
techniquement aujourd'hui à date on n'a
pas trouvé où que ce soit dans what's
app dans facebook dans les applications
mobiles
d'aidé géant d'internet
une façon d'écouter activement à la
population parce que parfois on peut
avoir qu on avoir l'impression d'avoir
une conversation qui a été goûté alors
que tout simplement c'est un mot-clé
qu'on a utilisé sur internet qui en fait
à déclencher l'envoi de publicités en
fait ils ont déjà tellement donné sur
vous que la plupart du temps ils sont
capacité effectivement de vous cibler au
plus près et c'est tellement perturbant
qu'on a l'impression qu'ils sont très
très proches de nous on sait en revanche
que facebook a déjà écouté certaines
conversations des utilisateurs de son
service de messagerie messenger mais ces
enregistrements n'avaient pas été fait à
l'insu des utilisateurs puisque les
captations utilisés étaient des messages
vocaux envoyée messenger critiqué pour
cette pratique le géant américain a
admis en 2019 avoir réalisé ces écoutes
pour vérifier si le système
d'intelligence artificielle du réseau
les interpréter correctement et affirme
également que les transcriptions était
anonyme enfin il ya le cas des
assistants vocaux qui sont intégrés dans
nos téléphones comme si riche et apple
bixby chez samsung cortana chez
microsoft ainsi que dans les enceintes
connectés type google home éco dot
d'amazon ou encore hommes quittent
d'apple pour les plus connus un
assistant vocal chez un micro ouvert
alors effectivement on écoute passif la
plupart du temps mais on écoute active
parfois
au beau milieu de votre salon dans votre
chambre à coucher dans la chambre et aux
enfants et vous avez payé pour ça de
notre point évidemment les enceintes
connectés et assistants vocaux ont la
capacité technique d'enregistrer en
continu puisqu'ils sont faits pour ça
mais ça ne signifie pas pour autant
qu'ils analysent tout ce qui est dit en
permanence mieux le gagne pas beaucoup
d'argent c'est pas sur les 20 ou 30
euros que coûte le que coûte l'assistant
de google qui vont se faire de l'argent
c'est sur toute la donne et si qui vont
récupérer d'après un test mené en 2019
par l'entreprise - des rats spécialisés
dans la cybersécurité nos échanges sans
avoir sollicité les assistants c'est à
dire sans avoir prononcé d'ici riz ou
auxquelles google pour enclencher la
détection ne serait pas traitées et
analysées via internet l'entreprise a
utilisé deux appareils un android et un
apple chaque téléphone a été exposé à
une salle complètement silencieuse puis
une salle avec une vidéo youtube parlant
de nourriture pour animaux on voit
clairement sur ce graphique que sans
sollicitation avec les mots clefs pour
activer l'assistant aucun échange de
données n'a été signalé le seul moment
où des données ont été envoyés c'est
lorsqu'un dc riz hockey google ont été
prononcées surtout que faut raison
garder dans le sens où tout n'est pas
tout ce qu'on dit n'est pas intéressant
et la voix est vraiment quelque chose de
très compliqué à analyser ça représente
de tel volume de data que pour le moment
il n'ya pas les puissantes les calculs
qui permettent de gérer ce volume de
data
c'est la seule explication logique ah
non il n'y a pas de risques parce que
c'est trop énorme
même par en mettant des mots clés les
résultats sont rassurants mais pour tous
ceux qui ne sont pas encore convaincus
voici quelques conseils pour éviter
d'avoir à chuchoter à côté de vos
appareils équipés de micros la cnil la
commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés recommande de
privilégier l'utilisation de dispositifs
équipés d'un bouton de désactivation
physique du microphone et d'envisager un
moyen d'activation - un certain que la
détection de mots clés le conseil numéro
1 si on veut pas être écoutés et si on
veut une vie privée total c'est je
dirais presque que ça n'allait pas sur
internet
c'est un peu compliqué de par acheter
des enceintes dont on ne connaît pas le
fabricant des sous marques et c'est de
rester sur les grosses plates-formes
quand même c'est là où c'est à peu près
de plus d'encadrer et de penser à
éteindre ces appareils qui ont vraiment
n'a pas envie d'être écouté et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire un appareil est un
non pas en veille est totalement il nous
français
[Musique]